I don't like this Narrative of me being
a deflector you are what that means it
took us like six months to get one story
out of you that was personal I found
that this guy was prom King right like
you were grumpy exactly because why
would I ever why is that a point of
Pride dude that's in high school no it's
just interesting it's a good story this
is interesting tell the damn details hey
my name is Nick Dunn 10 years ago I was
a [__] prom cake
try to see if something was said and it
triggered him wanting to say it and he
couldn't
oh so Charles is the new king and he
goes
there must be a lot of pressure I think
I know how that feels
equating the royal family
it's a lot of pressure for them okay
that's why he's always asking so who's
your favorite Royal you guys that's a
prom King smile though I'll beat you up
dude
I always forget he could like kill
people whoop everyone's ass in here I
know I forget it's a cool thing to bring
up either